- CALL MY AGENT.
[cell phone ringing]
- JADEN PINKETT SMITH, MY MAN.
- WHAT UP, CLYDE.
HEY LOOK, MAN, I'M GONNA
BE REAL WITH YOU OKAY?
THIS "ALIEN BOY" SCRIPT,
I'M NOT FEELIN' IT.
I MEAN, IT'S HARD
BEING WILL SMITH'S SON.
I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
MY NEXT PROJECT REFLECTS
THAT I'M A DOWN-TO-EARTH,
NORMAL KID.
AM I MAKING ANY SENSE?
YEAH, YEAH,
I'M READING YOU LOUD AND CLEAR.
I'VE GOT A SCRIPT RIGHT HERE.
VERY REAL, CALLED "STREET BALL."
- TALK TO ME.
- OKAY, SO YOU PLAY TONY.
HE'S A KID FROM THE STREETS,
LIVES IN THE HOOD
IN A HOUSE
WITH HIS MOM.
- STOP.
HOUSE?
OH, IT'S LIKE A...
TINY MANSION.
- GOT IT, GO ON.
- SO HIS MOM AND HE,
UH, THEY LIVE IN THIS HOUSE
AND SHE WORKS
AT A SUPERMARKET.
- STOP.
- OH, YEAH, A SUPERMARKET'S
LIKE A MANSION,
UH, BUT IT'S FULL OF FOOD
AND ANYONE CAN GO THERE.
- SO, LIKE,
WHERE THE BUTLERS GO?
- YEAH, BASICALLY.
SO HE, UH--
- AND WAIT.
YOU SAID HIS MOM
WAS DOING SOMETHING
AT THE SUPERMARKET?
- WORKING.
- SO...
- WORKING IS KIND OF LIKE ACTING
ON A SET EVERY DAY
IN A FILM THAT
NO ONE'S EVER GONNA SEE.
AND IT LASTS
FOR THE REST OF YOUR LIFE.
- OH, LIKE A MAID!
- YEAH, YEAH, SHE'S LIKE
THE MAID OF THE SUPERMARKET.
- AWESOME, CONTINUE.
- SO ANYWAY, TONY DOESN'T
MAKE THE BASKETBALL TEAM, RIGHT?
SO HE DECIDES TO START
PLAYING PICKUP GAMES
OF STREET BALL OUTSIDE.
- SO HE PLAYS BASKETBALL
IN HIS PLANE?
- NO, ON THE GROUND.
- IN HIS LIMO?
- NO, UH, OUTSIDE
IS THAT STUFF
THAT GOES BY WHEN
YOU'RE INSIDE THE LIMO.
- OH, SNAP!
HE PLAYS BASKETBALL
OUTSIDE THE LIMO DOOR?
- YEAH, YEAH,
YEAH, YEAH, YEAH.
SO THEN HE GETS
REALLY GOOD AT BASKETBALL,
AND THEN BLAH-BLAH
BLAH-BLAH-BLAH, FAST FORWARD.
AT THE HEART OF THE STORY TONY
HAS TO CHOOSE BETWEEN HIS MOM--
- CHOOSE.
- YEAH, "CHOOSE" IS WHEN
YOU HAVE TO MAKE A DECISION
BETWEEN TWO THINGS YOU WANT
BUT YOU CAN HAVE ONLY ONE.
- BUT...THERE'S TWO.
- YEAH, BUT, I MEAN,
HE CAN'T HAVE BOTH.
- [scoffs] WHAT'D I SAY
ABOUT SCIENCE FICTION, CLYDE?
IT'S A NO.
- OKAY, WE'LL PASS.
ACHOO!
- DAD BLESS YOU.
- THANKS.